I actually wanted to tell you guys
something some of the deals that we've
got going ahead which you're all aware
of and you've all agreed and confirmed
on so one of them is we're paying six
thousand pounds a month on the interest
for the 400,000 pounds loan that we've
got for the castle did you know that
yeah did you know that six thousand
pounds of monthly interest which is just
insane considering that we've got so
much money in the bank yeah it's
ridiculous
so we've said that we're gonna pay that
off would you agreed
yeah second thing is we're buying a
piece London Lincoln Bond son and
Lincoln which is three hundred and forty
thousand pounds and then we're gonna
build six houses on it which is going
ahead and then the third thing is we
agreed to lend you know that new money
lending business that we're gonna start
which we spoke about if you've heard
about we're gonna set up a business
whereby you know I'm gonna do property
down yeah we're lending people money
right and then give them a give them a
will have a charge on the property or
whatever and then we'll get a fixed
return may be around somewhere between
twelve and twenty percent ROI short-term
loans to get people back to the final
stage such as Saint who's a virtual
swarthy guy friend of mine we've agreed
to lend him two hundred seventy five
thousand pounds now why are you guys
have all been wandering around doing
nothing thanks no that's not true is
that obviously he's been swimming around
oh no well I've been swirling around
doing nothing I've been working on these
and all three of those things have
basically come to fruition today right
cool so such a science thing has come
the land in Lincoln we're completing on
tomorrow and this list is asking for the
money and the bridging stuff that now
accepted that we can pay that off stop
paying so much interest on it so it's
all come off together which means that
today is really good news but the bad
news is today we're gonna have to
transfer over a million pounds out of
the account okay it's fine what do you
have you feel about others good all
these things that come off though right
and we've got way why over a million
pounds in the bank so we can sleep in
the car at the weekend
how much smiles Goa it's about a million
smile I can't smile my business partner
I just need your your your like go-ahead
to send a million pounds out we've got
about in the account planner it's most
the money gone yeah but it's gone on
really good stuff
so anyway is that cool with you it is
good it's good yeah all together it's
not right we've got if we're there card
but we also we also we also said that we
would never get a message dredging we're
less than million in the account yeah we
did say that we need more money in the
account Nick never well yeah I felt like
ass person or we could just not transfer
a million out and then we're them with
them with golden I understand what
you're saying when we gonna get started
as money back tablets it's quite a long
time it's quite a long time what about
the link on one yeah someone ever gonna
see that money again so yeah yeah
someone's like starting over
yeah
I think we're gonna have to do though
which is part of the plan isn't it
I'm not sure but you really want to keep
the four hundred thousand pound for the
castle on by 18 percent ROI on it
no maybe I've got more money coming in
anyway always but there's a lot of money
going out as well as how much how much
is in the account all together right now
I don't think is is it not I think it's
about but they'll still still have us
before 2000 we've got a lot of money
coming in even things you're asking me
right we're not I'm not looking at the
accounts I don't I don't know what's
coming in and what's going out right
right right now let me know in a bit
that by the end of the day if you want
to pay off that ribs for money or not
Wednesday we've got a pair tomorrow
those did I did I caught my swing all
first thing in the morning all right all
right let's call one then good that's it
you